as promised I found some old photos of
you are you better boy oh gosh how old
are you there I think second grade oh my
god you're adorable look at that you
have that big ol hair going even then
you were like y'all ain't ready for my
hair okay two things about three things
about that I've got the reins in the
wrong hand
that is my brother Pike's calf Ropin
horse he wasn't working too good for
pike so Pike said I could run barrels on
him and I am rocking the plaid pants yes
you are yes you are man fashion icon
okay next oh that day Kelly I want a car
for six months what I would have won a
Ford Torino car for six months and all
you had to do is fill out your little
questionnaire thing and then that is the
Kiowa cowboy high school band right
there
oh my you see the guy on the right Roger
wheels he he is said the band leader for
Alan Jackson
oh no and there's Susie's in the middle
and Pike on the left
Gary Rayburn and Kelly Ron your whole
family sings that's what I find I know
that and I know a lot of people do know
that but it's insane like I'm talking
like everyone seems like well like it's
crazy well daddy I somebody asked daddy
one time said Clark do you do you play
he said I used to play on the linoleum I
love it okay next okay oh my gosh oh
that's Wynonna in Trisha yeah Bruce hint
yeah cute look at your hair you are so
cute look at all y'all are so cute when
was that I don't know where is it
you all have records uh-huh go to your
all your records yeah I got this is what
I'm talking about see this is 90s
country right here like all these women
represent and right now and like they
don't play women now hardly on country
what's wrong with y'all
I know next oh that was for the duets
album and while you came and sang with
me it was so magical it's so funny
because remember we actually recorded a
different song first uh-huh and then we
ended it in crossroads and then we ended
up doing because of you and it was such
a magical moment Kelly we look so young
I know I still look don't you tell shut
up oh I was here Kennedy Kennedy Center
Honors thank you for coming and singing
I will do anything for you ever
thank you very much I generally don't
get nervous but I'll tell you what I'm
about peed my pants at that was not was
rain I was nervous
okay next yeah okay ma'am well is this
in Vegas uh-huh
that's in Vegas oh my gosh next okay bad
about myself oh this is awesome what's
this oh that's what I'm was been in oh
my 40th anniversary have been in the
grand ole opry there's Vince Gill
Dolly Parton Carrie Underwood and you're
actually reuniting with Dolly and Carrie
yes dolly
Carrie and I we are going to be
co-hosting the CMA Awards this year
I can think of three better women thank
you do that thank you I'm thrilled
audacity accident we need a legend I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this